25 1550
un número que a lo mejor no dice mucho
qué pasa si este número lo dividimos
entre 365 335 son los días que tiene un
año
resulta que el número que nos hace un 70
lo que te puede ser otras palabras es
que la vida en promedio nos regala 25
mil quinientos cincuenta días
si agarramos un gotero serían 25 mil 550
gotitas que cada día podemos usar
ahora quiero comenzar contando una
historia
y esta es la historia de un pequeño niño
un niño que nació en una familia de
clase media en la ciudad de méxico y que
desde chiquito tenía muchísimos sueños
se quería comer al mundo de alguna forma
soñaba con ser batman
y este niño comenzó a vivir una vida de
muchísimo dolor
sus papás diversión desde muy chiquito
tuvo varios padrastros y esos sueños
cada vez se fueron apagando más y más y
más
es de un niño totalmente ordinario
y a lo largo del tiempo
este niño empezó entrar en una gran
depresión
al punto en el que dijo para qué estoy
aquí cuál es el propósito de mi vida
qué es la diferencia que yo hago
y esta depresión que normalmente tenemos
algunos jóvenes
no es algo poco común
muchas veces sufrimos y vivimos grandes
depresiones
este año el que te soy platicar lo soy
yo
y terminé estando así cuando tenía 17
años
queriendo morir
sin tener ninguna vocación nada que me
gustara nada que me motivara
y en algún punto conocí un concepto que
se llama la hipoteca social
una hipoteca social puesto en pocas
palabras es entender que la vida nos ha
dado mucho nos ha dado la oportunidad de
estar vivos la oportunidad de comer de
vivir y cuando entendí este concepto me
di cuenta no solamente que había tenido
el regalo de estar vivo sino que por más
que yo pensaba lo que no tenía me di
cuenta todo lo que sí tenía y los 17
años pensando en un momento cuando
entendía este concepto que aunque la
vida yo creía que no me había dado nada
yo le debía todo y no a mí a las
personas que estaban cerca de mí
es el momento en el que decidí
y hacer una persona ordinaria convertir
en una persona extraordinaria y no lo
digo por alardear no es difícil ser
extraordinario si te pones a pensar
sobre la palabra extraordinario la única
diferencia que hay entre ordinario y
extraordinario
es extra
es estar dispuesto a dar el extra en
esos pequeños momentos en los que nadie
más del extra
la gente extraordinaria normalmente
enlace como personas ordinarias a mí
este concepto me cambió muchísimo la
forma de ver y de pensar
y fue cuando comencé a trabajar como el
protagonista de mi vida
y esos son algunas de las cosas que de
las cuales he recibido aplausos de las
cuales he sido el protagonista porque he
tenido la oportunidad de ser el miembro
del 20 más joven que existido crear
políticas públicas o recomendaciones en
políticas públicas en materia educación
y empleo que van enfocado a los
presidentes de los 20 países más
industrializados del mundo o ponerle el
reto un día despertarme decir por qué no
recorro toda la península de baja
california en bicicleta cuando nunca me
había subido una bicicleta
y ahí fue en esa siguiente fotografía el
día que llegue a los cabos de mexicana
los cabos 14 días mil 625 kilómetros y
yo mejor que llegue en esa bajada
llorando y llorando de alegría porque
como era posible que esa foto de la
persona de 17 años que habían antes
pudiera haber recorrido mil 625
kilómetros
la vez que tuve la oportunidad de estar
en un panel en el g20 compartiendo con
el director general de google en europa
o cuando tuve la oportunidad de tener
una nota que se hizo viral como el
emprendedor
el mexicano que fundó seis empresas
sociales antes de los 22 años hoy tengo
25 se que nueve un poquito más grande
o cuando tuve la oportunidad y sigo
tener oportunidad de ser el presidente
del ig méxico una fundación que busca
crear una diferencia a través del
impacto social con los jóvenes o en cada
acción social que la vida me dio el
privilegio de edad y de servir sanz está
en las calles y toda la serie de
acciones sociales que hemos creado y que
hemos hecho
y lo que te estoy enseñando es la forma
en la que yo fui el protagonista de algo
extraordinario pero quiero decirte algo
que normalmente no vemos y es toda la
gente que es anónimamente extraordinaria
y son esas personas que no están ahí por
el aplauso o que no son la cara o la
representación de todas las acciones que
hay detrás porque cada acción que yo he
tomado en la vida ha sido gracias a
tantas personas que me han soportado a
mi familia a mis amigos a mis mentores a
mis maestros a mis colaboradores ya toda
la gente que está alrededor e incluso tú
viéndome eres parte de este apoyo porque
podrías nuestra aquí y en lo que hoy es
esto
lo que te dice es que no necesita ser
siempre el protagonista para hacer
alguien extraordinario si alguien
extraordinario es ponerle el extra en
esas pequeñas acciones y ahora si lo
pasamos un poco
en pensar de qué se trata la vida
tuve que pensar de qué se trata la vida
después de esto
y mi respuesta tuvo que ver con otra
pregunta
una vez le preguntaron que sabes el
nombre de tus bisabuelos
y yo te pregunto a ti te sabes el nombre
de tus bisabuelos
de todos
digamos con tus tatarabuelos que te dice
eso
aguas lo que eso te dice es que las
posibilidades de que tus bisnietos se
sepan tu nombre son muy poquitas
al final porque la vida se trata de
tener bisnietos y que sepan que
estuviste aquí que sepan que tú dejaste
un legado teniendo acciones
extraordinarias siendo un ser humano
extraordinario
y como joven a veces nos preguntamos qué
podemos hacer
es que los jóvenes no somos el futuro
esto en la frase que se decía desde hace
mucho tiempo los jóvenes no somos el
futuro
somos el presente porque hoy más que
nunca toda esta generación millennials y
todas las nuevas generaciones que vienen
estamos marcando un precedente y ser
joven
hoy en día tampoco es tan fácil
los jóvenes no necesitamos que nos den
las cosas no necesitamos asistencialismo
necesitamos sentirnos productivos y no
solamente los jóvenes la gente es muy
diferente entregar un pescado que apoyar
a que la gente siga pescando y lo
podemos poner como un concepto pero hay
algo en el hecho llamado ser productivo
que creo que es lo que dignifica más un
ser humano que es lo que más deja un
legado el día de mañana el poder saber
que tu valor en la vida produce y hace
algo el saber que vas a lo mejor y te
fletas trabajando ocho nueve diez horas
al día pero gracias a eso hay una
familia que come por ti hay una casa que
se mantiene por ti la productividad es
de las cosas principales para fomentar
una vida extraordinaria y de alguna
manera entender que podemos hacer todo
podemos imaginar absolutamente todo los
seres humanos somos el único mamífero
que tiene la capacidad de crear ficción
de imaginarnos algo no importa como
entrenes un chango
no importa cómo lo entrene sus cuantos
años / les no hay manera en que tú le
digas al chango dame tu plátano y el
karma te va a regresar 2
pero muchos seres humanos si lo creemos
y vuelta a ver el mundo en el que
vivimos es un mundo de pura fe de pura
ficción no es como que lleva un homo
sapiens así
y se tropezó con un iphone o de pronto
cayó un avión con el instructivo de cómo
despegarlo todo lo que hemos creado ha
sido gracias a la imaginación de alguien
que dijo y si dejamos de vivir en una
cueva nos podemos vivir una casa y sé
que no mejor se hablando de algo muy
tonto pero el mundo en el que vivimos y
es gracias a la gente que ha estado
dispuesta a soñar de forma
extraordinaria
las cosas no cambian nosotros hacemos
que cambien lo informe tiene una vida
extraordinaria de tener grandes acciones
sentado en tu casa esperando a que
alguien te toque la puerta abra la
puerta y te digan hola tú vienes a ser
empresario verdad ese es tu sueño a tu
sueño es casarte con el amor de tu vida
mira te la voy a presentar
y dice que probó la trillada pero muchas
veces pensamos de sampler a estar en tu
casa viendo la rosa de guadalupe nos va
a hacer que las cosas cambien
y yo te vengo a decir como creo que
podemos cambiar a méxico
porque méxico es simplemente un legado
de muchísima pasión de forma personal y
creo que de forma colectiva todos
queremos lo mejor y si te preguntas cómo
podemos cambiar a méxico es muy simple
número uno y la más importante empecemos
pensando locuras empecemos pensando las
cosas que probablemente no podrían
ocurrir imagínate que en la época de la
revolución de los derechos civiles en
eeuu hace años alguien se hubiera parado
y me ha dicho oigan los por ahí de los
2000 es va a haber un presidente de
origen afroamericano
barack obama imagínate que hubiéramos
tenido un tema hace 100 años no como si
fuera a llamar porfirio díaz o como tú
quieras
y que asesinan es un número para volver
a dicho hey les garantizo que en 100
años las mujeres van a poder votar
otra de las grandes locuras que en la
ficción de los seres humanos hemos
creado y que hoy tenemos como una
realidad lo que estoy diciendo es no es
tan imposible es muy posible que podamos
hacer que las cosas cambien y los
siguientes participando y lo vuelvo a
decir es algo que normalmente ves en
cualquier publicación de redes sociales
pero no participamos nos quejamos
necesitamos participar tener pedagogía
social conocer lo que está ocurriendo
para que no pensemos que la opinión de
política que tiene nuestro tío el
domingo en la comida es la verdad y
sabemos perfecto a lo que me refiero
y participando significa involucrando t
yo he participado en todo tipo de
iniciativa juvenil jóvenes coparmex en
la que team ágiles y en casi todas
siempre dicen nosotros no queremos ni
tenemos nada que ver con política y yo
me pregunto cómo es posible por más que
yo la iniciativa social si no lo hacemos
de una forma política si no lo hacemos
ley podemos organizar la cantidad de
brigadas de recolección de basura que
quieran en la calle que quieran todos
los días ir pero hasta que no haya una
propuesta de política pública o una ley
que realmente castigue a la gente que
tira basura puedes desgastarte tiempo
todos los días recogiendo basura es
cuando más necesitamos participar es
cuando más necesitamos saber la
diferencia entre mayoría o mayoría
calificada para cambiar una ley o para
cambiar la constitución y eso ocurre
participando involucrándolos
siguiente tengamos paciencia pero
también trabajo mucho trabajo hay una
gráfica que es entre el tiempo y el
progreso imagínate que tú nunca has
jugado tenis nunca en la vida y te llevo
a tu primer clase de tenis cuánto
progreso vas a tener la primera clase
muchísimo porque porque no sabías
absolutamente nada de tenis
ya habla mejor sabes que hay una raqueta
que hay una pelota que hay cuadrantes y
alamera con suerte le pegas segunda
clase vuelves a tener bastante progreso
a lo mejor ya te echaste una red y
pudiste agarrar 23 puntos tercera clase
cuarta quinta sexta clase el tiempo va
recorriendo pero el progreso se topa y
esto es exactamente igual en todo todo
tiene un tope en el tiempo y el progreso
y sabes que las cosas extraordinarias
ocurren del otro lado de ese tope y es
cuando más tiempo le quieres dedicar
para ese pequeño progreso los atletas
olímpicos se lo dicen un atleta olímpico
entrena ocho nueve diez horas diarias
por años para bajar milésimas de segundo
porque esas milésimas de segundos son
los que hacen la diferencia entre el
primero y el segundo lugar porque esas
milésimas ese pequeño progreso es lo que
hace que seas de rico a millonario esas
son las pequeñas cosas que hacen de ser
un cambio ordinario a un cambio
extraordinario
y pensando que todo siempre se puede esa
es mi frase de vida
todo siempre se puede
y no lo digo como una utopía o como una
fantasía todo siempre se puede si
estamos dispuestos a pagar el precio de
que todo siempre se pueda
y eso es lo que hace que seamos
extraordinarios
sabes que yo no te digo esto porque yo
me considero una persona de esos casos
raros de esos casos que de pronto nació
y bajó de un lugar o de una comunidad de
muy escasos recursos y empezó a trabajar
y es una persona completamente ordinaria
que vivió y ha vivido una vida
totalmente ordinaria y creo que por eso
de alguna forma puedo hablarles al oído
porque yo sé cómo siendo ordinarios si
estamos dispuestos a poner el extra
tú y yo podemos hacer toda la diferencia
y quién sabe quién sabe si aquí hasta el
próximo activista o si el que me está
viendo es el próximo presidente de la
república pero son esas pequeñas cosas y
esos pequeños detalles que marcan toda
la diferencia
porque al final
es todo lo que tenemos
es todo lo que tienes
[Música]
tienes 25 mil 550 días
para hacer algo extraordinario para ser
mejor ciudadano
y yo sé que muchos de sus goteros ya
están medio gastados
pero solo tienes 25 mil 550 días
sabes qué
para que ser normales
si se puede vivir con un poquito de
locura y un tantito de pasión
hagamos una gran diferencia muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]